today on twitter i saw
an interesting post that made me recall
a place
where i'd worked when i was 20 and 21
years old i've worked a lot of different
jobs many of them outside of the academy
and one of the places that i worked was
shaky's pizza restaurant
in waukesha wisconsin it's no longer
there
as a matter of fact i don't even know if
there are any shakies left at this point
in time but i thought that it would make
for an
interesting story and it might spin off
into a bunch of stories because
you know frankly i i worked there for
quite a while and there were a lot of
things that went
on that could be interesting to talk
about so here was the tweet it was
what was the most coming-of-age indie
movie
job you ever had and then the person
talked about you know working in
a place in new jersey and then i talked
about
you know working at shakey's pizza
restaurant
and the way that ended up happening is
i got out of the army in
1990 in the the
end of the winter it was march
and i moved back in at my mom's place in
waukesha
and i needed to find a job because you
know she was going to charge me rent and
you know i was happy to live at home and
contribute i was actually eating quite a
lot at the time
as i usually did back then i had a super
high metabolism
and so what i did is i i walked down
highway 18
and just kind of looked around and
thought you know i'll go in
and get applications at every place
within
more or less walking distance and so
that's what i did
and shaky's pizza restaurant got back to
me right away
and i i suspect in part because i
already had restaurant
experience having worked at kentucky
fried chicken
and having worked at ponderosa
steakhouse
also walking distance from from where i
lived at the time in waukesha
although the the ponderosa was just a
very short walk
and the kentucky fried was about
three miles down the road or so and i
but i would walk it at night you know
after i closed
so they got back to me and i remember
getting called in
and having an interview with the
assistant manager
and i'm trying to recall his name the
other one's name was jim this guy
this guy was a former coast guard
officer
and he was a cool guy he was the day
manager and then the other guy was the
night manager
and then there was a manager and owner
of the stores
who was a real jerk and i'll talk about
him in a minute so anyway i sit down
with this guy
and you know he's like oh you got out of
the army i was like yeah budget cuts and
you know there's a whole story to tell
there and we started talking a bit about
like
you know typical service stuff i think
no matter what branch of the service
somebody's been in
there are some things that you can
relate to right
and so anyway he and i we hit it off
pretty well and he's like hey can you
start
uh how about next week monday so
i came in and the very first thing i
learned to do
was to prepare the buffet because back
then
you know it was the early 90s and so
pizza restaurants are no longer just
doing pizza they also had buffets of all
sorts of stuff they put out pizzas they
put out
shakies had these things called mojo
potatoes i'll tell you about them in a
moment
and then there'd be other things that
would be in there like onion rings
and i don't remember what other fried
things we had but then there'd be like a
salad bar
and puddings and all sorts of crazy
stuff there
and so you could you could come in and
you could order a pizza
or you could order the buffet and then
you could get some pizza with the buffet
and
also get um whatever else you wanted to
eat right
there was also like a soft serve ice
cream thing in the corner
and then there was also a bar and so
that you know after i trained on like
setting things up
and you know i did some washing dishes
because i already you know
washed dishes in other places and they
were starting to show me about like you
know how to make pizza how it goes
through the oven
how to make the mojo potatoes they were
like well
you know you content bar right and and i
was like
yeah i guess why not so they're like
okay
and then i actually trained with the
manager's dad
that was kind of a sad story that guy he
um
he'd been actually through world war ii
he was that
old and he um
was a driver for for an officer in the
army
and they drove all over italy and this
officer was kind of a script so he told
all sorts of cool
stories about the trouble that they got
into and you know
uh the things that they avoided and the
things that they did and
the the rare times that they actually
saw combat
and so this guy would you know he he had
a lot of great stories
and he you know you could tell he'd been
tending bar for quite a while
and like i said he was the the father of
the
the manager and the owner and and that
guy treated him like crap
you know i don't know what sort of beef
there was between him and his dad
but the guy who owned the place was was
a real piece of work
and he treated his dad you know he made
his dad his employee
and so he could boss him around and tell
him stuff and
you know i i watched that and i was like
man i
i would never talk to my dad that way
but
that was that so he he's like well you
know there's the beer
you know i'll teach you how to pour the
beer properly and then
people would often get wine and we had
all these wine glasses hanging up there
here's how you clean them up and polish
them up and we'd have these big
jugs of gallow wine so people would come
in at lunchtime you know business people
and they'd get sloshed they'd get like a
picture of beer
and sit there and have their pizza and
have a meeting
uh you know you could actually hear them
talking about business stuff
and then they'd go through a picture or
two while they were having their their
meeting
and then at nighttime same sort of deal
people would come through
that was basically it you know there was
soda there was a beer and there was wine
so you know no hard liquor or anything
um
and you know as time went on i got to
know the different people there
you know every every restaurant is kind
of its own
microcosm there's personalities and with
them personality conflicts
and you know some of the people were
cool some of them were complete jerks
and everything
in between you had sort of your
stereotypical
kind of things like the kid who is
working who's going to high school
and definitely isn't going to college
and is working his butt off
to pay for his car and his insurance
that he uses to get to his job
and doesn't have much of a life because
of that you have your sort of like
20 something mid 20 something
professional
cooks and and servers whose life is
kind of going nowhere at that point in
time
you know because they're it's a shakies
it's not like they're working in a
high-end restaurant
or anything like that where you're going
to learn some valuable skills
this is the kind of job that back then
in the 90s you could
take or leave you could literally walk
down the street
or go through the want ads and just
circle them
and find job after job after job like
this there were a lot of jobs back in
that time they didn't pay well
but you know the benefits were you know
you could you could cram food in your
mouth and
eat it up when the boss wasn't paying
attention and
at night you know it's kind of funny the
night manager was kind of a screw-up
he actually ended up getting in a lot of
trouble because he embezzled
things went off the deep end for him he
paid for his his uh girlfriend's
education
at carroll college and you know she
would come in and we'd be like
man she's way out of his league um what
is she doing with him and
and we'd look at it we'd be like well
there's dollar signs clearly
in somebody's eyes here he was in love
with her
as soon and she he was paying for her
entire education
as soon as she graduated she broke up
with him
he went off the deep end started not
caring about anything which meant that
if you closed at night you could drink
as much beer as you wanted to
and he was letting you know these 16
year old kids drink beer as well
so that was kind of kind of crazy
but you know it was it was kind of fun
as well to to get to
close up and and have some you know
decent beer and
sit around and shoot the breeze and then
then go home
and i did this job um full-time
for quite a while so it would have been
from march
of uh 1990 to
when i went off to college in august
of 1990 right and so actually i would
have been 19 at the time because i
turned
20 in august and then i went off to
college
and i came back for the summer
and stayed at my mom's place again in
waukesha so that would have been the
summer
of 1991
and i worked that whole time as well and
there i had a really
cush arrangement because i was sort of
you know i was returning
and i could do so many different things
i could like
take the deliveries that came in and
sort them out and put them in the cooler
i could cook i could wash dishes i could
make the potatoes
uh which again i'll tell you about in a
moment because they were pretty
distinctive
i could get the line ready i could clean
i could bartend i could
you know handle all sorts of cool stuff
and so um that summer
i had this this really interesting set
of shifts i would begin
uh on i think i was doing it closing
either sunday night or monday night i
worked six days
and so i would close then i would go
home and sleep then i would go back
there
and open up right and then i would have
24 hours before the next time
that i would come in and close and then
go to sleep
then open and i would do that three
times in a row
and then i would get weekends
essentially getting 48 hours free and
then we'd party right so
you know i was i was doing the sort of
thing that we we did back then
and it was like the perfect schedule for
me
i was getting overtime and you know you
like i said you'd eat pizza and eat mojo
potatoes and stuff like that while
you're working there
i think if i remember right we'd get
like one free meal a day
and so i would just like stuff myself
i could eat a lot of food back then and
so
okay i'll tell you about the potatoes
because you're probably curious
so shakies did this this thing these
were really distinctive for shakies
called mojo potatoes you would have this
slicer
and you'd have these giant garbage cans
obviously not filled with garbage but
they would get filled with potatoes and
water
and these were like you know like 50
gallon oil drum size
containers so you'd pull that over to
this this slicer thing
and you'd take the potatoes and you'd do
like you know bags of 100 pounds of
potatoes at a time
put the potato in there pull the slicer
down it would cut it into like four or
five
you know big wedges um you know slices
essentially
and then you'd throw it in the water as
a matter of fact it went into the sink
then you have to pull all these potatoes
out and you put them in the water and
they'd soak in that water
overnight and then you'd take them out
and when you needed to make them
that's when the cooks would come and get
them and they'd pull them over by the
fryer
and first they'd go into the chicken
batter
and it was dry right so they'd be coated
in like chicken
stuff that's right we we fried chicken a
lot as well
and so the potatoes are now coated in
this this chicken thing
you throw them into the deep fryer and
they would come out you know be like a
big slice of potato like this big
and that thick and it was really good
i mean really really good since they'd
soaked up all that water they were kind
of
i won't say juicy as such but they were
they were moist inside
the outside was hard and crisp and you'd
put like
ketchup on it or people put all sorts of
different sauces on it and that was one
of the things
shakies was was known for and so
people would come from all over the
place for these mojo potatoes
when i worked at the summerfest ground
we basically
as far as i remember just made two kinds
of things
pizza makes sense shaky's pizza and
mojos and
and we were just like mobbed you know
people were all over the place
i think if i remember right i worked
both summers
at summerfest because it was extra money
and it was you know i'd be at the
summerfest grounds and
so i'd ride in with somebody and have a
good time and i remember another thing
it was hot as hell in there
um middle of summer you got all these
fryers going
ovens going so but it was it was a good
time
and you know i'm it's a sort of work
that i think you do when you're a young
person
and you know you make some money you get
to meet some people
you learn about the world a bit you
learn about what to do what not to do
you don't really learn much about the
culinary industry as such at working in
a place like that but you learn
something about it and then you know
another thing that was kind of cool
with shakies that i'll mention and then
i'll i think i'll reserve the rest of
this
for other stories the more that i
remember about it
um the guy who owned this shaky so
shakies was a franchise
he had two one was in waukesha and the
other one was somewhere
in one of the suburbs of milwaukee i
don't remember exactly where maybe
wauwatosa
maybe maybe one of the other places and
i only went there a couple times to to
that place
but we would get deliveries and
he also owned the warehouse that the
deliveries were coming from
so it was you know integration of
these two shakies and then the
deliveries that would go
from the warehouse out to all the other
shakies around the state
so one day you know i would always get
the deliveries
and i'd put them away and i got to know
the delivery guys pretty well
one day um in these deliveries there'd
usually be two guys with a truck if
they're going around the state of
wisconsin
and one guy was sick and so the the
assistant manager was like
hey how would you like to go on a
delivery route
and help out and i was like i mean
is it like just a normal day and they're
like yeah you'll be back here by the
time that you punch out
you know it'll be fine if it takes
longer you know
we'll give you the extra time and we'll
actually pay you at a higher rate and as
soon as i heard higher rate i was like
sure i'll do that so i knew the delivery
guy
hop into the truck with him and we go we
start driving and we went all
literally all over the state you know of
wisconsin
you know we stopped in madison we
stopped in all these little towns where
there was shakies
and the one thing that i really remember
about
it because i don't remember too much
about that trip was when
we were driving along and we went around
a curve
and something went wrong the load
shifted as they say
and you know things weren't packed
properly i guess or tied down
what would i know you know i'm just some
kid riding along right
and suddenly like the whole truck just
lurched
and we almost went off the road and you
know we slowed down we pulled off on the
shoulder
and we were like looking at each other
me and the driver and i'm like
what what the hell was that you know and
he's like the load shifted man we got to
go back in
and check it and so we got the truck
stopped
and we go inside and lift up the you
know the door and stuff like that and
stuff starts falling out
that's a bad sign right there when
things are propped against the door
and so um there was all sorts of stuff
all over the place it was a real mess
you know i'm looking at it i'm like wow
you know this is this is a real problem
not really my
problem as such but this is a real
problem
and i'm looking at the driver you know
and then i felt bad of course for the
guy
because now he he has to make
everything fit and figure out what he's
going to substitute for deliveries
and then he's going to have the boss
chewing his butt out
once he lets him know that there's been
some damage and spillage and all that
and and we start going in and looking
around and actually it turns out it's
not that bad
but the load really did ha you know it
moved around
in the truck sufficiently to to like
shift the truck
as we were driving so we get everything
tied down we make the rest of our
deliveries and we come back home and i
i do remember he said like i don't think
you need to say anything about this
when you get back to the store and i was
like
fine by me man you know i don't know
whatever happened to that guy he was
he was probably in his 30s or 40s you
know so he'd been doing that for a long
time he might have been a lifer
um so you know shakey's kind of an
interesting
period in my life um happened
both after i got out of the army and
before college where i was working
full-time there
and then you know it was it was a summer
job
while i was in college and you know it
was cool because
like i said got to eat a lot of good
food not really good for your food but
but
tasty food and it was i was probably
there
when shakies was in
you know if not its heyday at least it
you know sort of
its glory days before things started to
tank
i don't know if you can find any of
these restaurants around anymore
but it was uh it was quite a place
to work in and i learned a lot while i
was while i was on the job there